all right let's look at a couple of
other things from the Trump rally over
the weekend there were a number of
esteemed dignitaries and very high
profile guests at this rally in Waco
Texas to kick off the 2024 campaign for
Donald Trump one such dignitary was Ted
Nugent and Ted Nugent kicked off the
rally in Waco by saying that Russian I'm
sorry Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is a quote homosexual weirdo
which I have to admit I have not heard
before
I want my money back I didn't authorize
any money to Ukraine to some homosexual
weight weirdo
yeah I won my money back okay sounding
like a whining child but in all
seriousness as we've talked about before
some of the biggest Applause lines among
the American right wing over the last
two years are overtly homophobic and
transphobic lines and that was indeed
the case at the Trump rally maybe my
favorite moment from any recent rally
including this one was a guy who got up
on stage and instead of promising to fix
the supply chain he said he would fix
the chain supply
I've got a plan to fix the chain supply
oh these people uh if you if you were uh
aware of the distinct lack of chains
that we have in this country
this guy is going to fix it for you
I've got a plan to fix the chain supply
it's called re-elect Donald Trump yeah
so anyway very soon chains will be back
in the United States here's another
really interesting moment
um one of Trump's attorneys who also
moonlights as an anchor for right side
broadcasting Christina Bob she spoke to
a guy
who brings up that he served in the
Marines and then she says oh what's your
MOS now that's just a specialty it's a
it's super General it's like oh avionics
or like intelligence it's super just
super super General Moses are not
classified in any way or secret or
confidential and the guy reacts weirdly
to the point where five different
current and former Marines wrote to me
and said David this guy's lying no
former Marine what answered this
question in this way you tell me what
you think is this guy making it up here
we go did you serve I did where where
did you sir Maureen me too what was your
MOS I was special oh I see okay
I flew into places okay where were you
dark places where were you stationed I
uh can't go into detail okay but this
interview is over it's all super super
secret now again MOS just means military
occupational specialty it's just a super
General role were you in personnel and
administration were you in logistics the
guy could have just said I was in
intelligence I was in avionics I was
whatever it's really tough to tell
whether it's completely made up but
again current Marines wrote to me and
said David this stuff stinks to high
heaven this guy is just straight up
making it up if he did serve and he's
just wacky right now because he's you
know infected with the Trump virus fine
but uh many members of the military in
our audience
extraordinarily skeptical about this
guy's story then a a January 6th
indictee as I understand it named Mickey
was there and gave a very strange
interview is the only way I can describe
it I was in isolation 51 of those days
read nothing
food in my mouth my Lord Jesus my God
Almighty and the support of a nation and
I knew that in my heart I knew that
my negative 48 family my proximatian
family the whole world can cause crazy
if you don't care yeah oh I don't I
could not have done it
without my presmanian family demontre if
you don't know dematria it is one is two
c is three anyway I'm not going to
continue with this it goes on for a long
time but quite it just to the untrained
diet seems like very very significant
mental illness here's another guy who
wants to do a citizen's arrest of Alvin
Bragg there's an idea Alvin Bragg of
course the Manhattan district attorney
who might might might indict Donald
Trump for itself arrest Alvin Bragg uh
Alvin Bragg is overstepping his
boundaries we the people are calling for
the arrest of Alvin Bragg four crimes of
treason election interference I don't
even know if that's a crime but election
interference obstruction that's the
critical moment from the interview
he's Furious and he's confident that
Alvin Bragg should be arrested but he's
not actually sure whether the things
he's mentioning to justify Alvin Bragg's
arrest are crimes beautifully emblematic
of this entire thing Josh is even lying
to a grand jury Trump done nothing wrong
we're here to show support for the
greatest president ever Donald Trump
arrest Alvin Bragg you know in South
Carolina you could do citizens arrest
yeah so if Alvin Bragg ever comes to
South Carolina arrest them there you go
so a very very patriotic idea there and
then
um uh what else do I have here he uh
lastly here is a woman who says she's a
South African Maga preacher
who had God come to her in a dream and
told her to move to the United States
and try to support Donald Trump which
again this would likely be medicated in
most psychiatric situations amazing
what's your name and where are you from
Lindy and hoppley and I am a South
African Mega preacher no
Africa now I'm living in America uh
because God actually told me that
there's a Revival Coming to America and
in the dream that I had president Trump
was in it so Yep this is totally normal
I'm all about just praying for this
country and seeing God get his full
reward that's amazing where do you live
here in the United States I'm in DFW so
we came down with a trump train with all
the Texans you know going crazy all the
um trucks going crazy is about right
it's just honking and going wild it's so
great to see how many patriots there are
and so many supporters of just this
great movement fantastic and what is it
about President Trump that you love so
much
well to be honest I just started
dreaming about him I am you know I have
a prophetic gift and the Lord started
speaking to me about him totally not
just conversations with the Lord she's a
prophet and in my one dream I actually
choose because I'm totally not political
I'm a minister I travel around the world
you had me full
World To Shine Your Light and don't hide
it underneath
girl and had an encounter with no you
were I I don't see it
but what I loved about this is that I
actually in one of my dreams I sat in
front of prison Chomp and I knew he was
giving me some type of job you know I
was kind of like and I said to I'm the
Lord in my dream I said I don't want to
lose my Ministry for this all right so
anyway as we've talked about before
mental illness not a joke very sad need
to increase access to mental health
treatment in the United States let's
leave it there with the South African
Maga preacher but that is what this is
where we are right now as far as the
Trump movement and it is a really scary
and sad thing